another helping hand for those who  really need it most this christmas  holiday  the local injured police officers fund  along with other community partners  teamed up here  for a day-long toy drive organizers tell  us they were able to help  make christmas a little more special for  about 2 000 families yesterday  and among other things they handed out  new clothes toys bikes blankets and food  these families are not going to have the  christmas that we all  typically have and  we're just happy to give back there's  going to be another toy drive like this  sunday at the iglesia evangelical church  that is on civic center drive